birds and casinos set to reopen tomorrow
Johnson exciting news it is the exciting
this is our new theme by the way our
economic engine closed for two and a
half months because of the corona virus
pandemic this morning Hector Mejia is
live along Fremont Street where there is
a countdown to reopening after it good
morning to you there is good morning and
yesterday we got confirmation that the
de Las Vegas and the Golden Gate are
reopening the hotel today at 11 a.m. and
out here we have some maintenance going
on the screen though looks like it's off
that countdown was playing out on the
vivo vision canopy screen and down below
we are spotting what appears to be metal
detectors here along Fremont Street and
they are counting down until the gaming
industry is allowed to reopen the casino
floor that will happen at midnight
Fremont Street six-cd block
entertainment district shut down back in
mid-march we're still dealing with a
corona virus pandemic so a number of new
changes are in place for visitors and
for employees here at properties all
across the valley measures to force
social distancing increased cleaning and
screening of employees and guests in an
effort to convince tourists to fly here
CEO Derek Stevens give away two thousand
free flights to Las Vegas as part of his
keep America flying promotion ended up
adding more flights after they were all
taken up within hours and it's also
important to note that only a few
casinos will open right after midnight
others will wait a little while longer
into the morning or even months until
they reopen also they are reopening at a
time when others were boarding up their
storefronts in an effort to protect
themselves from potential looters that
we've been seeing popping up during the
protests reporting live this morning
Hector Mejia 8 News now